[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima on Monday  night's episode of The Bachelorette  the man drama came to a head I get  tickled when I smile at an angry man  gets angrier I poach her on the shoulder  I didn't talk to you doc Neely yes and  Rachael Lindsey just couldn't take it  anymore  the beautiful Bachelorette had a  breakdown the pressures that I feel  about being a black woman and what that  is and how I'm talked about it I get  pressured from so many different ways  being in this position and Dean made  this declaration the only people that  have seen Lee pick fights with have been  not the people that he's used to seeing  on a daily basis from a cultural  perspective and we got this cliffhanger  next week the drama explodes it's rotten  shortstack southern piece of garbage you  won't believe what happens when Lee and  Kenny go head-to-head what did you guys  think of Monday night's episode and  whose side are you want let me know over  on Twitter  [Music]  you